[Music]
it is Gamescom 2017 my dudes and I'm
here with willpotter we just played one
of the hottest games at the show perhaps
one of the hottest upcoming games
Dragonball fighters or fighters II
depending on which corner of the
internet you frequent
so will you play this a bunch of times
it's my first time playing yet so I'll
start off by saying holy moly that is a
good fighting game it's incredible and
just just watching it in action is is a
piece of art I think yeah I think that
that's the thing that we were talking
about yesterday so we didn't we had like
half an hour with it which although it's
a lot simpler than many many other
fighting games there's not enough time
to kind of figure out the intricacies of
how the mechanics work it has a lot of
like simple commands you know one button
combos but there's enough there for the
people who know what they're doing to
kind of figure out the depth they're
tagged in other characters create long
supers and assists and that kind of
stuff but what we talked about
afterwards was this is a good fun game
for people who just don't even like
playing games yes I'm not very good at
fighting games but I love Dragonball and
and I was really pleased to find that if
I could just mush a couple of buttons
their character pulls off some
incredible moves yeah and it should with
some like powerful blasts he moves and
it was really easy to play and I wasn't
for tough at all yeah and the kind of
commands to do all the cool stuff is
really really simple and I think that's
one of the things that be like Budokai
and Billiton series has been difficult
with cuz they've been in 3d space so
you're doing a lot of like moving around
trying to catch up your opponent and
then charging and there's like stop and
start to it whereas this is usually just
like you hit two buttons and you'll
vanish and appear behind them and as
long as you press an attack button it
will do like a really crunchy kick or a
punch that like ground pounces are more
off a wall and then you just hit a few
other buttons and you're doing like
called Dragon Ball Z stuff it felt just
like the anime it's not like we were
playing scenes yeah and we could even
pair up characters against each other
like recreate scenes from the
or even like put Trillian against
Android 18 like husband and wife you
could sort of put together your own
scenarios yeah it's really fun
so like Android 18 was it who's the
other one Crillon was new and was it 16
yes 16 and we play Trump's yeah trunks
as well so those were the first a
piccolo was there as well so those are
the first time those have been available
to play publicly and like again like we
said it's difficult to say how they play
in terms of like mechanically we can
tell that they all feel quite different
trunks is got great range because of its
sword it doesn't have that many sword
moves he's got loads of like punches and
kicks as well but like he's great for
like catching your opponent by surprise
like doing a vanish you know
teleportation and just hitting them with
a sword you'll have it's like
deceptively large range
Piccolo's got his limbs and he's got his
you know special beam cannon which is
like again catching people of God but
like the thing that we should really
like talk about is is the presentation
is unreal like like he said it looks
incredible but like the attention to
detail there were points where like
moves that they were doing I remember
specific scenes of when they happen yeah
absolutely and the one that kind of
really got me was VG is overhead like
his overhead is like a leaping elbow
drop I was like I've seen you do that I
know the exact kind of frame in the
manga and the anime but yeah it's real
it was really good to feel like we've
got a good deep Dragonball Z game for
the first time in a long time absolutely
yes yeah so I think that between that
and Marvel vs. Capcom infinite it's a
good time for fighting game fans
injustice is killing it right now they
just announced Hellboy you can check out
the trailer for that on youtube.com
forward slash GameSpot Hellboy that's a
big deal he's been gone for ages never
been in a fighting game so that's that
you should check that trailer it's
really cool and for more games phone
footage and impressions and podcasts and
all that other stuff check out the
YouTube page subscribe while you're
there and we'll see you around